[Music]
julian is with us in
jacksonville florida hi julian how are
you
i'm doing better than i deserve dave
good how can we help today
so i had a question for you i wanted to
ask you if i should start a business
right now at this point in my life
why not so i'm currently 22
uh i'm about to graduate college in
about two semesters
and i was very fortunate to have
worked when i was in high school at one
point i was doing almost 30 hours a week
while in high school
and through a very aggressive portfolio
i've managed to
end up buying a house at this point so i
currently have
a house that i bought and i'm moving
into it in august at this point
what are you studying so i study
computer science
okay so i'm an engineer for computer
science
and what's the business you're going to
start while you're in school
so i was we were going to start an
electric mobility
business for personal transportation so
this would be arranging everything from
electric mobility for older uh people
and as well as small personal
transportation like electric scooters
and skateboards
sounds interesting he said we you and
some friends
uh so all so the ideas and all the
designs are mine uh i have
a few friends that i'm considering
bringing on uh i haven't
decided 100 on that yet
okay
okay so you're going to design for
instance a scooter
have it manufactured and sell it correct
so it'd be small scale manufacturing um
some of the initial market research i've
done as well as
i have my uh i have all the supplies and
everything already set and ready and
based on that it makes
it makes economical sense to do it so
walk me through that part what are you
selling them for what's the total
dollars involved
uh so we're we're aiming to have about
three different models
ranging from a 500 people this is for
electric scooter parks at least
ranging from 500 to about 1200 uh for
the 500 we're looking at
about uh 250 manufacturing and selling
for 500
and for the upper end for the 1200 one
we're looking at about six hundred
dollars to manufacture
and the twelve hundred dollars to sell
all right and that line's about
that's about lined up with what the
current market and what wholesale value
and how many would you do in your first
run
i'm sorry how many would you make in
your first run
um so we were going to sell locally
first
uh and we were going to do about uh 100
of each model
six hundred thousand dollars correct
and where's this money coming from
uh i was very fortunate to have been
investing money in the stock market
um and i just ended up with
quite a bit of money and how much that's
kind of where i am right now
how much man so so right now
uh including so i just bought the house
so i'm sitting on about
uh around 400. do you pay cash for the
home
i did pay cash for the house correct so
the 400 including the house
and as well as all the taxes for the
capital gains have been paid off
no i would not start this business
no i would not start this business
here's why here's the rule of thumb that
i use
anytime you have to james bond the deal
you don't do the deal james bond
in every movie is playing cards with the
villain
and puts all his chips on the table for
one hand
if he loses that hand the world gets
collapsed
and we all die if you put four hundred
thousand dollars there only four hundred
thousand dollars
into scooters and they don't sell you're
screwed
you're back to zero no i would not bet
the farm on one hand
that's bad diversification it's bad
economics it's bad business
practices you would need to start much
smaller than you're talking about
starting
and prove your concept somewhere other
than
in your dreams so are you saying
i started or just start small i'm saying
start uber
uber small very very small not with uber
i agree but start
like one tenth of what you're talking
about if you want to put 60 grand of
your 400 in
and go sell those and then use that
money to buy the next batch and that
money to buy the next batch fine
am i dropping 600 in when i've only got
400 and this thing turns sideways and
you end up with zero and a bunch of
scooters in your garage
no thank you
and julian he's only teaching what i've
i've watched him do
the man has moved yeah here's what
here's what happens man
because i i am i've been doing this
running this business for almost 30
years
yeah we made almost all of our money
julian off of 10 of our ideas the other
90
of our ideas sucked
every entrepreneur experiences that you
guys in the public never see
most of you never see the 90 of our
ideas that sucked
but if we had scaled them all to use up
our entire net worth
on one of those ideas that sucked we
would have been out of business
instead you do you run test markets and
you prove
you do social proofing on this somewhere
other than your research of the
marketplace
you actually go sell something because
people when they're taking surveys and
they say oh yes i would buy that
they lie until you ask them for their
freaking money and then when they give
you real money
and there's a transaction that occurs
that is market research dude
that will get you there so no i do if
the only way to do this
is for you to spend all of the money
that you have
on this one play only to find out that
you're late to the scooter game that
bird already beat you there
only to find out that electronic skate
boards are now out of business because
everybody keeps cracking their head open
and nobody wants to ride them anymore
only to find out the things that are
happening in the consumer marketplace
that you couldn't
see with your research lens and then you
lose it all because you bet the farm on
one horse race and you lose the family
farm
no that is a lack of diversification
that's james bonding it
and i teach small business people this
all the time in entre leadership if you
got to slide all your chips to the
middle of the table
and that one that one hand of cards then
you're making a bad play
that only works in the movies that only
works in some book that some guy wrote
where he forgot to tell you about all
the fish he didn't catch
before he caught the big one because the
truth is in the real world
90 of our ideas suck the truth is
there's three rules of business
it takes twice as long as you think it's
going to it costs twice as much as you
think it's going to and you're not the
exception those are the three rules of
business
and i man i've experienced that i
knocked all the hair off my head dude
and i i don't want you to have to
experience it the wrong way yeah
one of the reasons i went broke in the
real estate business is i had all of my
chips
on the table in one business model that
was broken yeah
and when the business model when the
cracks in the business model happened
and the business model
you know crashed in on my head i didn't
have anything left it broke me
and it's a lack of diversification it's
a bad it's bad business process
yeah so don't do it but i like the way
you've outlined it i like the way he's
thinking though dave as far as and i
want to be
i never met a 20 year old that ran up
400 000 bucks in the stock market
exactly
i'm curious about that too but yeah but
you know just assuming
this you know it's 100 percent let me
tell you here's the problem jillian
you're you are unbelievably smart
and that might be your biggest handicap
that's true
you're going to overthink crap and
you're going to you're going to have an
intellectual arrogance that because
you're so stinking smart
that's going to cause you to step in dog
poo and you're never going to see it
coming
because you you were looking and i'm
telling you some of us are a little
dumber we got an advantage
because you you obviously been 20 years
old you're you're a
freaking savant man doing what you're
doing it's awesome i'm so proud of you
pay cash
but do not bet the farm on this you you
i don't know what you did right they got
you to 400 but it got you there
and i'm happy for you that you got it
but now
from there what i would do is use
standard business acumen
and let's test market this let's pilot
it
it with a tenth of what you're talking
about where if you lose 60 grand
and instead of 400 you got 340 i'm not
so pissed
you lose this whole thing because bird
comes along and eats your lunch with a
scooter world or something
i just don't i don't want you to do that